well let's get more now on that
conservative leadership election as the
candidates rally mps for the next round
of voting on monday last night the five
contenders met in the first television
debate and today former chancellor rishi
sunak has received the backing of ben
hodgson the conservative mayor for ties
valley he's been speaking from there
let's take a listen
well it's great to be here and have the
support of my friend ben houch and the
mayor of teas valley we worked on lots
together including setting up this new
free port which is bringing jobs and
investment to the area now our country
has serious challenges but i'm going to
be honest about them grip them and deal
with them responsibly but be in no doubt
our country also has limitless potential
and places like t-side are a fantastic
example of that as chancellor i
delivered for t-side and as prime
minister i want to spread that same
sense of optimism and opportunity across
the united kingdom so we had our first
leadership debate on tv last night how
do you think it went how do you think
you performed
i was i was really pleased to be able to
make a positive case for why i can be
the best leader for our party and our
country and that's because i want to
restore trust rebuild our economy and
reunite our country i was pleased to
take the positive case for that
they're quite adversarial aren't they
competitive the very nature of those
sort of debates i mean are you
comfortable criticizing your colleagues
you know i've got enormous respect and
admiration for all of my colleagues who
are standing to be leader and it's right
that we have passionate debate about
these issues and when this election is
over we have to remember we're all part
of the same conservative team the same
conservative family and we're going to
come together and serve the british
people taxation was one of the main hot
topics last night did you see yourself
as a socialist chancellor no absolutely
not you know i think the number one
economic priority we face as a country
is inflation and i want to get a grip of
inflation because inflation is what
makes everybody poorer and if we don't
get a grip of it now it will last longer
and that's not a good thing once we've
done that i will deliver tax cuts but
we're standing here today in a fantastic
example of a brexit opportunity
pro-growth policy that i delivered as
chancellor this freeport and as we know
that it's bringing jobs and investment
to this area that's the kind of
pro-growth policy that i will pursue as
prime minister you've been leading the
way in the in the rounds of voting with
the mps what's going to be different
when you're talking to the to the party
faithful when it gets to that stage
should you be in the last two
yeah i'm going to continue making my
positive case for my candidacy and i
believe i am the best possible person to
help our party defeat kierstarma and
beat the labour party in a general
election winning across the country in
places like t-side but elsewhere as well
that's what the new leader needs to be
able to do they also need to be able to
restore trust rebuild the economy and
reunite our country and i believe our
best place to do all of that i think one
of the other elements last night that
caused quite first debate was the the
concept of gender identity where do you
stand on that you know i i've been clear
about that i'm the father of two young
girls and i want to make sure that
women's rights are protected whether
that's in sports in changing rooms or in
language but of course i respect
everyone's freedom to love who they want
and live as they live but we must be
unequivocal as i am about protecting
women's rights just one question about
the prime minister he's having a
farewell party this weekend should he
not be chairing the cobra meetings
so i you know i'm out making the
positive case my candidacy in this
election i'm sure the prime minister and
the rest of the government is working
hard continuing to serve the british
people
in terms of the leadership race the
bookies have got you in second place
despite the fact that you've been
leading so far do you think that
what will change if you do become prime
minister because
a lot of people in this part of the
country lent their votes to to break
down the the red wall previously what
will will help you
get those votes or maintain that support
in this part of the country when it
comes to a general election if and when
we have one
well you asked about this part of the
country as chancellor i have delivered
for this part of the country there's a
treasury campus a new economic campus
just up the road in darlington the new
freeport here which is attracting jobs
and investment to the area town centers
in middlesbrough red car darlington
thorna beyond all being upgraded and
reinvigorated transport improvements
going in at darlington train station and
more importantly a new sense of optimism
and excitement in this area i helped to
deliver that as chancellor working with
a fantastic conservative mayor ben
houchin that's why people can trust me
to keep delivering for t side but also
places like this across the country
that's what i want to do as prime
minister i was going to say you've
clearly earned the support of
ben houch and how important is it to
have the support of someone like him oh
it's incredibly important ben is a
fantastic local mayor he's a fantastic
champion for his community and to have
his support means the world to me and he
and i have worked on many things over
the years and i'm delighted to be able
to keep working with him i hope as prime
minister keep delivering for the people
of t side as we have over the past few
years but then also
spread that same sense of opportunity
and optimism across the united kingdom
because our country has limitless
potential and as prime minister that's
what i want to unleash okay one last one
one tv debate down two to go are you
looking forward to both of those sunday
and tuesday you know i'm really enjoying
making a positive case for my candidacy
i believe i am the best candidate placed
to not only win a general election but
also restore trust
rebuild our economy and reunite the
country